bonsoir et bienvenue dans municipales
2014 allons passer en revue l'actualité
des municipales à moins d'un mois du
premier tour de scrutin ce sera le 23
mars pour la première fois le front
national sous la bannière rassemblement
bleu marine présentent des listes dans
le département avec 23 listes annoncé le
parti de marine le pen espère décrocher
30 postes de conseillers municipaux au
soir du deuxième tour
alors quelle est sa stratégie anthony
rech ce fait le point la leader
frontiste est enthousiaste et pour cause
23 tête de lice sont annoncés pour cette
élection municipale un score historique
car en 2008 il n'y avait eu aucune liste
fn sur le département
arrivé à avoir 23 tête de liste avec
déjà un grand nombre de ces dix qui sont
d'ores et déjà bouclé c'est un très bel
effort d'implantation locale c'est une
priorité pour le front national
sur les 23 candidats neuf listes
seraient bouclés et pour les autres elle
aurait déjà réuni près de la moitié de
colistiers soit environ 600 personnes à
cette énorme c'est complètement inespéré
et c'est vraiment exceptionnel - je m'y
attendais pas du tout français au départ
faire une liste un versailles et puis il
ya eu un certain nombre de gens qui sans
doute ont été attirés par le fait que
dans les yvelines on a exactement à 100%
on calque notre politique sur celle de
marine le pen
des candidats se sont notamment déclaré
à plaisir et leur cour ou encore
montigny le bretonneux leurs programmes
appliqués ni plus ni moins les idées
classique du parti frontiste sur cette
élection locale
l'insécurité la préférence nationale
pour l'emploi des français issus ou non
de l'immigration la lutte contre les
trafics de drogue ou la non augmentation
des impôts
ma plus grande crainte aujourd'hui sur
montigny c'est l'immigration
on a vu certains quartiers comme le
quartier des prés comme le quartier du
pas du lac changé de physionomie et
c'est inquiétant parce qu'on est en
train de mettre en application sur
montigny comme dans d'autres villes de
la de la ville nouvelle
les directives gouvernementales et si
ces candidats passent l'obstacle du
premier tour
pas de question de quelconque alliance
avec d'autres partis il ne maintiendront
bien sûr au second tour car nous voulons
absolument porter la voix du bon sens
dans les conseils municipaux et il nous
apparaît que en matière de bon sens
l'ump le ps
ont quand même énormément de retard en
gagnant des sièges dans les communes les
plus importantes la stratégie du fn et
de peser par la suite pour les élections
européennes
pour l'instant l'objectif sur le
département décroché 30 postes de
conseillers municipaux le 30 mars
prochain les candidats frontistes
devront toutefois convaincre les
électeurs de se déplacer sur une
élection locale est votée rassemblement
bleu marine
ce qui n'était encore jamais arrivé dans
les yvelines
et puis toujours concernant donc le
front national rassemblement bleu marine
philippe chevrier a déposé sa liste à
rambouillet un autre candidat également
à déposer sa liste
nicolas bauer à elancourt je vous
propose d'écouter quelques-uns de ses
points de programme
notre programme se base sur une charte
qui était dite et la charte du
rassemblement bleu marine qui se il ya
plusieurs points le premier point la
priorité c'est la baisse des impôts ce
qu'on va proposer mon présent pour les
héros pour toi une baisse des impôts
locaux
on défendra la laïcité républicaine
partout on sera respectueux de
l'environnement de l'urbanisme
on proposera des référendums locaux pour
toutes les questions importantes et je
pense notamment aux projets de pistes de
ski artificielle sur la colline
d'elancourt on propose aussi d'autres
choses
on est vide a man la lutte contre
l'insécurité
agir pour la sécurité c'est la première
des libertés c'est fondamental
redynamiser les quartiers on nous dit
les socialistes ne disent elles en cours
c'est une ville dortoir mais pourquoi
est elle en cours est une ville dortoir
parce qu'à de la sécurité et parce que
les airs courtois ne sortent pas le soir
voilà le la réalité des choses pour
voilà pourquoi c'était une ville dortoir
moi j'ai des témoignages sur le terrain
les gens en ont marre des incivilités au
quotidien des agressions des rixes de la
drogue
bon je veux pas faire un nom plus l'état
catastrophique de la ville mais en tout
cas ça existe et je pense que rien n'a
été fait et dépôts de listes vont
démarrer le tracé gris elles seront
closes le 6 mars ce soir nous nous
intéressons aux candidats de la verrière
ils sont deux le maire sortant alain jaj
face au candidat investi par l'ump et
lui dit nicolas dainville leurs
portraits signer yolaine thorez les gens
qui ont envie qu nommés à vie continue
un comité de soutien ils peuvent signer
pour lyon voilà au nom je suis pas une
star mais je suis amer non je suis maire
communiste de l'intérieur depuis près de
deux ans à l'arrachage 56 ans est
candidat à sa succession
il avait été élu par le conseil
municipal à la suite de la démission de
pierre celle en cours qui officiait la
tête de la ville depuis 1983 dans
l'immeuble d'à côté ça c'est vouloir
c'est intime accueillera d'accord
volonté est arrivé à l'arrière en 1987 à
linge a notamment été premier adjoint au
maire et vice président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aujourd'hui
soutenu par le parti socialiste pour ces
élections
le maire sortant aussi directeur général
adjoint d'un organisme de logement veut
continuer à mener sa politique actuelle
j'ai envie
d'avancé sur deux pieds le pied de la
quotidienneté parce que nos habitants
sont très attachés à ce que nous nous
préoccupions leur vie quotidienne que
nous les accompagnons dans les
difficultés qu'ils peuvent rencontrer
mais aussi dans la gestion quotidienne
de la ville la propreté la sécurité on
vient d'en parler sur la tranquillité la
la la la la la le développement de la
vie associative et c'est donc tout ce
travail du quotidien ça c'est le premier
pied le deuxième pied c'est le projet le
projet parce qu'une ville a besoin de se
développer
et puis des réponses au coin du
quotidien se font dans le cadre du
projet l'emploi le logement il faut
pouvoir construire accueillir des
entreprises et donc qu'il faut avoir des
projets parmi ces différents projets
celui appelé gare beckham nous allons
redonner des espaces naturels qui sont
aujourd'hui pas utiliser parce quelle
bécane personne n'y va c'est pas une
zone accessible
nous allons les restituer en agriculture
urbaine en parc paysager en et surtout
nous allons donner des réponses à des
gens qui ont besoin de logements
d'emplois de services et de commerce
donc c'est un projet phare mais il n'a
de sens que si celui en regard aux
préoccupations quotidiennes des
habitants face à lui nicolas dainville
27 ans diplômé d hec habitants de la
verrière depuis trois ans est soutenu
pour ces élections par l'ump et lui dit
il ya quoi faire pour notre ville donc
on se mobilise beaucoup de veyrier roi
qui sont dans notre équipe qui se
bougent sur l'emploi la réussite des
jeunes avec le numérique dans les écoles
ce passionné d'entrepreneuriat travaille
actuellement à la mairie d'elancourt et
son cheval de bataille
et c'est aussi la famille comme valeur
fondamentale je suis sans étiquette
j'ai jamais fait partie d'aucun
mouvement politique après j'ai des
valeurs très fort des convictions
personnelles très présente sur la
famille g10 même si beaucoup mobilisée
contre le mariage l'adoption des couples
homosexuels
je mobilise maintenant contre la théorie
du genre dans les écoles des choses qui
inquiètent beaucoup les verts hiroire
donc c'est des convictions qui me
tiennent à coeur et j'ai envie de
défendre aussi dans ces élections
municipales pour sa première élection il
a fixé trois axes prioritaires
alors on a trois axes un l'emploi
priorité emploi ouvrir une maison de
l'emploi m une pépinière d'entreprises
dans les bureaux d'alcatel qui sont
vides depuis 96 formé à
l'entrepreneuriat il ya plein de jeunes
qui ont envie de s'en sortir son livre à
eux mêmes deuxième axe et l'éducation
des jeunes c'est le numérique dans les
écoles les cours d'anglais par
visioconférence pour mettre les nerfs
dans une immersion totale qui s'en remet
à la bonne au bon accent qui forme
l'oreille et qui est interdit
tableau numérique interactif dans chaque
classe ce n'est pas du tout le cas que
les profs se reformer pour vraiment
avoir une pédagogie qui implique plus
l'élève
le troisième axe est la sécurité et le
cadre de vie
merci monsieur bonne chance à vous les
deux hommes seront opposés lors du
premier tour des élections le 23 mars
prochain
nous changeons de comment nous
intéressons maintenant à elancourt
quatre listes devraient être déposées
celle du maire sortant investi par l'ump
du déni jean michel fourgous celle de
son opposant socialiste michel besson et
puis deux autres listes l'une du
frontiste aux nicolas bauer et l'autre
sans étiquette de christian nicol leurs
portraits signés wilfried récit 2008
trois listes à elancourt mais jean
michel fourgous maire sortant réélu dès
le premier tour avec près de 58% des
suffrages face à son principal
adversaire le socialiste michel besson
cette année les deux principaux
candidats se retrouvent pour un nouveau
face à face mais il devrait aussi
compter sur les listes du front national
menée par nicolas bauer et du collectif
sans étiquette génération solidaire
menée par christian nicol à 26 ans ce
cadre en informatique et le benjamin de
cette élection
souhaitant s'engager avec des amis dans
une ville qui l'a vu grandir
il a frappé son succès aux portes des
formations politiques mais semblerait
que dans les listes traditionnelles
il est derrière des équipes qu'ils
soient prêts construite et qu'ils soient
déjà en place et que disons qu'ils
acceptent peut-être on va dire d'écouter
certaines idées où certains projets mais
ils ont deux manières avec une certaine
distance dans les points du programme
que nous sommes en train de développer
ces dernières semaines et va y avoir par
exemple le fait d'améliorer leur
dynamiser le centre ville puisque donc
ils encourent est une belle ville qui
peut avoir maudire des gros avantage
mais le centre ville
n'est pas très développé donc nous avons
accès un des points de la campagne là
dessus
nous voulons aussi essayer de travailler
sur les journées qui permettent de nous
rassembler de nous unir épisode mais
j'en ai les plus convivial que ça puisse
être le 14 juillet que ce soit les fêtes
de noël ou ou d'autres moments qui
permettent de tous nous rassembler de
profiter de la vie de la ville il faut
qu'ils en cours est une âme qu'elle
encourait est un coeur lui aussi mène
donc sa première campagne nicolas boer
40 ans encartée au front national depuis
2010 est arrivé sur la ville il ya 14
ans moi je défends des convictions je
défends des valeurs qui sont clairement
pas celle de l'ump et du ps
d'accord ça il faut que c'est vraiment
que nos adversaires ne comprennent pas
ce qu'ils nous disent on n'a pas les
mêmes valeurs et moi j'ai envie de leur
dire effectivement on n'a pas les mêmes
valeurs que nous parce que nous nos
valeurs c'est l'intégrité
c'est l'insincérité c'est l'honnêteté
tout le contraire de l'ump s de ce
qu'ils nous ont montré depuis 40 ans qui
est le mensonge la trahison et la
corruption sécurité fiscalité
quelques-uns des points de programme
d'un candidat qui souhaite aussi
implanter durablement le fn dans la
ville et dans la circonscription
ces deux listes qui viennent donc
concurrencer celle de l'ump et du ps le
ps qui annonce avoir fait l'union de
toute la gauche des verts au parti
communiste avec un programme qui mise
sur une redéfinition des priorités de
hausses d'impôts mais des fonds utilisés
différemment
michel beso 53 ans élan courtois depuis
30 ans les militants socialistes depuis
la fin des années 70 et vous verrez
contrairement à ce qui est dit à
longueur de journée les impôts
monté en cours depuis il faut créer un
échange il faut créer un dynamisme
soutenir épauler les landes pour toi qui
sont en difficulté mais pas que et de
façon à ce que tout le monde puisse bien
vivre dans cette ville
tout est mis sur des obsessions de vraie
obsession du maire sortant est rien pour
l'ensemble des élans corto jean michel
fourgous en poste depuis 1996 il brigue
un quatrième mandat lui qui a perdu en
2012 son poste de député des yvelines
face à benoît hamon il veut prouver que
cette victoire de la gauche était la
conséquence d'un élan national est pas
une sanction de sa politique
un maire qui sait se faire entendre sur
le plan national sur les questions
économiques ou encore d'éducation sa
ville est en pilote en matière de
développement du numérique à l'école
aujourd'hui il entend en faire
comprendre que les communes ont besoin
de résister face aux choix du
gouvernement pour être mère oui il faut
vraiment quelqu'un d'expérimenté en
matière de gestion du facteur humain de
gestion économique
1 et puis de comprendre quand même le
système de montage d'un dossier
aujourd'hui pour une collectivité qui
est très compliquée avec tous les
acteurs
vous êtes sur un bateau vous étiez force
il ya deux ans vous êtes pas sa force 5
là et demain vous allez passer à for
speed for suite attention sur un bateau
ou pou démâté quelques 16 mille
électeurs sont appelés aux urnes à
elancourt allez vous le savez la
rédaction propose depuis la mi février
le débat entre les différents candidats
deviennent pour faire part de leurs
propositions mais surtout échanger
autour des enjeux de leur ville et je
vous propose maintenant de revoir les
meilleurs moments alors nous avons
démarré par coignières le débat a été
diffusé le 18 février dernier
en plateau les deux prétendants le maire
sortant ump henri pailleux élu depuis à
1986 et son challenger socialiste didier
fischer qui siège au conseil municipal
au sein de l'opposition
leur principale préoccupation l'emploi
la ville de coignières affiche un taux
de chômage de 12 % alors que la moyenne
départementale est à lui pour cent j'ai
créé il ya vingt ans une un service
économie emploi qui met à la disposition
de tous les chemins de coignières d'un
téléphone internet qui leur donnent tous
les jo de kipré qui proposait des
emplois et de plus lorsqu'ils ont un
entretien on leur payait avant le
déplacement
par ailleurs j'ai fait un forum de
l'emploi qui se déroule généralement
d'octobre-novembre qui accueille tout un
autre pays s'ils recherchent des
recherches des salariés et qui est
fréquentée par environ un millier de
personnes des 1300 en 2013 est là et
bien ma foi également on favorise
l'emploi et par ailleurs il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui s'implante sur
coignières et quelquefois de grosses
entreprises eh bien nous mettant à leur
disposition des salles municipales
pour l'heure les entretiens vous nous
parler effectivement de la cellule
emploi qui a été créé
pour aider les chômeurs donc moi je suis
finalement favorable évidemment à toute
cette activité en faveur de l'emploi
mais on trouve aujourd'hui que cette
cellule emploi est insuffisante un
monsieur le maire c'est pas parce qu'on
met à disposition quelques ordinateurs
que l'on parvient véritablement à
accompagner vers l'emploi
un certain nombre de chômeurs nous notre
ambition c'est de créer un véritable
centre de ressources en fait pour
l'emploi avec un accompagnement et avec
des gens qui est compétent qualifié qui
accompagneront ces chômeurs la rédaction
de cv là le suivi quotidien en quelque
sorte du
de la personne qui recherche de l'emploi
c'est tout cela qu'on souhaite
véritablement mettre en place j'ai quand
même fait de coignières une des villes
qui en 86 avait 243 entreprises
j'ai fait du lobbying je dirais pendant
30 ans j'ai réussi à ramener un nombre
extrêmement importante
800 aujourd'hui j'ai fait tout ce que
j'avais à faire je dirais pour attirer
développer l'économie de coignières et
je n'ai aucune inquiétude le commerce se
porte bien mais comme partout bien
évidemment il y enseigne qui ferme mais
il y en a d'autres qui ouvre
immédiatement dès l'instant où un
magasin est vacant dans l'est dans les
deux trois mois donnant à 30 milles et
de les remettre aux cris d' israël fait
le guet je pense qu'il faut poursuivre
c'est un des grands enjeux de l'avenir
c'est pour suivre effectivement le
développement économique sur coignières
il faut aussi nous en avons souvent se
diraient nous l'avons évoqué en conseil
municipal
il faut aussi penser avoir une attention
particulière aussi pour tout ce qui est
commerce de proximité qui en grande
partie malheureusement disparu au coeur
de notre commune et on sait que les
commerces de proximité qui restent sont
quand même très fragile
donc je pense qu'il faudra faire un
véritable effort dans ce domaine là moi
je proposerai si je suis élu bien
entendu un jeu propre je proposerai un
plan de maintien et de soutien enfin de
maintien et de développement exactement
au commerce de proximité sur coignières
voilà un débat sur première coco et bien
entendu retrouver sur le site internet
de tv fil 78 un site dédié aux
municipales à les autres débats aussi
sur un duo de candidats c'est à bois
d'arcy un débat diffusé également le 18
février
claude juillet le maire sortant
socialiste élu depuis 95 en face de lui
philippe benassaya investi par l'ump élu
d y un débat attendu vous allez voir
entre les deux hommes autour du sujet de
l'aménagement du coeur de ville c'était
dans notre programme
on a fait ce qu'il fallait pour mettre
en place ce coeur de ville en sachant
que mon prédécesseur monsieur gombert et
notre municipalité acheter des terrains
et des
du foncier autour de la de la mairie
pour un jour pouvoir mettre en place et
construire ce coeur de ville
donc vous souhaitez lors du prochain
mandat le réaliser fils d'alma il ya un
certain nombre de choses ont déjà été
faites notamment le perdre le permis de
la nasa qui a été adopté en conseil
municipal
fin novembre il ya coeur de ville et
coeur de ville c'est vrai que les
prédécesseurs de monsieur ville et ont
dû avoir probablement une autre
conception d'un projet de coeur de ville
à partir du moment où on veut faire 375
logements dont 30 % de logements sociaux
sera carrefour c'est repassera centre
ville
c'est sur un carrefour qui est déjà
totalement saturée 375 logements ça veut
dire qu'il y aura 700 à 800 voitures en
plus sur ce carrefour
donc c'est totalement démesuré mais le
pire dans cette affaire c'est que
arcisien ont démontré leur hostilité à
ce projet là notamment dans les
concertations dans les réunions mais la
mairie est passé outre
comme d'habitude sur les projets en
essayant d'imposer un projet pour
probablement modifier la sociologie de
la ville à des fins probablement
électorale moi ma conception est
totalement différente
c'est la conception du cadre de vie on a
changé d'époque on n'est plus dans les
années 70 et 80 où il fallait bétonnée
aujourd'hui on est dans la protection
des familles et protection
d'environnement
quand vous expliquer qu' on est passé
outre toutes les eaux pas non mais ça ce
jeudi vous permettez que je puisse
terminer à 10 c c'est complètement et
erronée des réunions publiques ont eu
lieu
des explications ont été données une
enquête est un questionnaire a été sur
le site des arcisien avait la
possibilité d'y répondre pour certains
ils ont répondu qu'on dit les arts
sixième semaine tendue support le
document jeudi qu'il voulait pas trop
structures en hauteur vous en faites un
air plus qu'à tout r + 5 sur le centre
ville envahie rien n'avait pas suivi
l'avis d arcy siens ont ces questions
mais c'est terminé je sais que je vien
répondre justement faite sur ce point
appréciable précisément
donc il ya eu des ateliers qui ont été
programmées les gens se sont inscrits
s'engager à venir aux deux ateliers
il ya eu un travail important de fait et
je crois que il ya eu une réunion de
restitution de du travail de ces deux de
ses ateliers et on appris je me
semble-t-il en compte ce qui a été dit
dans les ateliers où vous êtes
incompétent et vous n'avez pas vu le
dossier du conseil
jamais vous les avez consulté cédric
rossi municipal monsieur le maire de jeu
murray porte des wc faudrait juste que
de lui répondre je m'énerve pas du tout
je vous allez voir c'est donc vous étiez
présent au conseil que ça a été voté
du 28 novembre et la délibération qui
concernait le coeur de ville
il était dit programme global
prévisionnel de programmes d'une surface
globale de 30 mille mètres carrés est
composé des éléments structurants
suffisant il propose la construction
d'environ 370 logements sur des hauteurs
r + 4 maximum refusée par les arcisien
monsieur le maire c'est ça que je ne
sais si c'est ça si vous perdez c'est
une contre-vérité désert s'ils ne
veulent pas sur ce que c'est ouvert là
sur ce problème sans gravité mais vous
le voulez mais j'imagine que vous
aimerez ce projet à son terme si vous
êtes région vous annulerez si jamais
c'est totalement marqué mais oui
absolument
pour conclure juste sur ce dossier on
seront une véritable concertation
exercice bien pour décider ensemble d'un
vrai coeur de ville vers voilà un débat
également on pouvait retrouver sur le
site des municipales de tv fil 78 points
dernier extrait du site concerné le
débat magny les hameaux
deux candidats également le maire
sortant bertrand guillon socialistes
opposés à une candidate investie par
l'ump lui d aurore bergé une campagne
tendue entre les deux notamment quand il
s'agit d'évoquer les problèmes de
logements sur la commune
j'ai un certain nombre de personnes y
compris d'ailleurs dans ma propre équipe
qui attendent depuis dix ans dix ans
pour avoir des logements adaptés à leur
nouvelle vie de famille parce que les
familles ont évolué parce que des
familles se sont séparés parce que des
gens ont eu plus d'enfants et je ne
comprends pas que des familles puissent
être dans une attente aussi longue pour
obtenir des logements adaptés quand en
plus on sait qu'ils sont simplement voir
intégrer propres à la part des communes
sur la région parisienne mais non c'est
bien là on dit on n'y peut rien c'est
pas à moi si j'ai décidé de m'engager en
politique c'est parce que j'estime qu'on
peut faire quelque chose ça veut dire
qu'à l'échelle de communes on peut aller
contre une tendance plus responsable
voilà il faut faire autre chose il faut
pas vouloir s'engager
politique il faut pas vouloir encore
plus devenir maire d'une commune lorsque
quand vous êtes maire vous avez un vrai
pouvoir sur ses discussions avec les
bailleurs sociaux au tout début de
l'intervention de rouen verger vous
disiez qu'il y avait cette discussion
déjà si vous voulez depuis très
longtemps déjà
nous avons des rencontres plus que
trimestriels avec tous les bailleurs
sociaux pour travailler avec eux
justement sur parcours résidentiel de
nos habitants cetinje s nous travaillons
avec eux sur le parcours résidentiel des
habitants est également nous travaillons
d'ailleurs avec eux sur les questions de
sécurité aussi madame berger ça tout à
fait et puis également également
actuellement nous travaillons avec eux
mais c'est beaucoup plus long sur le
parcours résidentiel c'est à dire pour
permettre à des gens qui sont sur des
dents les logements trop brand de
pouvoir accéder à des logements plus
petits mais en gardant à même tarif de
base sur leur location est aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs nous avions une réunion à ce
sujet avec l'ensemble des réservataires
avec l'ensemble des bailleurs
c'était mardi sur ce sujet pour pouvoir
mettre tout le monde autour de la table
et que tout le monde soit d'accord pour
que allocataires qui est dans un
logement trop grand et et cherchent un
logement trop petit puisse accéder donc
à ce nouveau logement ce que je vous
propose c'est d'arriver maintenant à vos
conclusions respectives et si vous
souhaitez aborder cette question
d'éducation ce sera le moment ou jamais
effectivement il reste environ voilà une
minute chacun pour conclure vous avez
débuté tout à l'heure bertrand guillon
or bergera donc le dernier mot je vous
laisse faire votre conclusion tout
d'abord écouté je suis un enfant de
manille je suis impliqué dans la vie de
notre commune depuis apparemment trop
longtemps pour madame pour madame bergé
mais avec une équipe qui se renouvelle
sans cesse et qui a à coeur d'agir pour
notre commune elle est soudée elle est
expérimentée et nous allons continuer
ensemble pour bien vivre à magny les
hameaux bien vivre ça veut dire
travailler au service de la famille en
priorité travailler aux liens entre
l'ensemble des habitants au parcours 2
des habitants travailler également sur
une ville qui est citoyenne et qui
respecte les initiatives citoyennes et
qui les accompagnent et puis travailler
également sur une ville de manille qui
préserve le cadre de vie dans lequel
nous sommes qui préserve le caractère de
nos hameaux qui met en valeur le
patrimoine historique et naturel de
notre commune mais qui permettent
surtout à chacun de bien vivre ensemble
amani viable or verger et ensuite on
affichera les temps de parole alors
écoutez moi j'aime mais ni m
j'aime cette ville je suis maintenant
depuis plusieurs années et j'ai la
chance d'être très bien entouré dans mon
équipe avec cette équipe manie nouvelle
énergie je crois qu'on porte en tout cas
je l'espère bien notre nom pour cette
nouvelle énergie que l'on a envie d'un
pull c'est mignon n'a entendu bertrand
you mais en fait on a entendu beaucoup
de choses
10 c'est long c'est compliqué c'est
difficile mais si on veut être élu on
peut pas dire ça on peut pas avoir comme
seule réponse à des projets qui n'ont
pas abouti selon ce compliqué c'est
difficile non quand on veut être et
meurt on doit être mère et on doit donc
agir agir 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
au service des habitants au service des
mamies quoi nous c'est l'engagement que
l'on prend parce que oui on aime cette
ville on veut qu'elle soit respectueuse
de son esprit village de son identité et
donc c'est la question de l'urbanisme
parce que oui on aime cette ville et on
veut qu enfin elles vivent et elle
respire c'est la question du commerce de
proximité
c'est la question la qualité de service
de la petite enfance aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous n'avons qu'une
crèche une halte garderie il faut que
les femmes s'inscrivent un mois à
l'avancé pour pouvoir faire garder leurs
enfants
c'est la question est évidemment aussi
comment créer de l'emploi sur la ville
voilà et puis sachez que les débats se
poursuivent sur tv fil 78 toutes les
dates de diffusion sont à retrouver sur
notre site internet dédié aux
municipales cette émission maintenant
terminé merci de votre attention et
bonne soirée